who was isaac newton
what are the things he contributed to
this world in the space of ideas
wow
who was he
he was born
in
1642
in
and near the small town of grantham in
england
in fact the house he was born in
and that his mother died in is still
there and can be visited
his father died
before he was born
and his mother eventually remarried
a man named reverend smith whom newton
did not like
at all
because
reverend smith took his mother away to
live with him a few miles away leaving
newton to be brought up more or less by
his grandmother
over there and he had huge resentment
about that his
whole life
i think that gives you a little inkling
that
a little bit of trauma in childhood
maybe a complicated father-son
relationship can be useful uh to create
a good scientist
it could be although this case it would
be right the you know
absent father non-father relationships
he was known as a kid little that we do
know for
being very clever about uh
flying kites and
uh there are stories about him putting
candles and putting
flying kites and scaring the living
devil out of people at night by doing
that and things like that making things
most of the
physicists and
natural philosophers i've dealt with
actually
as children were very fond of making and
playing with things
i can't think of one i know of who
wasn't
actually they're very good with their
hands and whatnot
he
was uh his mother wanted him to take
over the manor it was a kind of farming
manner they were the class of what are
known as yeomans
there are stories that he wasn't very
good at that
one day one of the stories is he's
sitting out in the field and the cows
come home without him and he doesn't
know what's going anyway
i
had relatives and
he manages to get to cambridge sent to
cambridge because he's known to be smart
he's read books that he got from local
dignitaries and some relatives
uh and he goes there as what's known as
a sub-sizer what does that mean well
it's not too pleasant basically a
sub-sizer was a student who had to clean
the bedpans of the richer kids
okay right now that didn't last too long
he makes his way
um and he becomes absorbed
in some of the new ways of thinking that
are being talked about on the parts of
descartes and others as well there's
also the traditional curriculum which he
follows and we have his notes
we have his student notebooks and so on
we can see gradually this young man's
mind
focusing and coming to grips with
deeper questions of the nature of the
world and perception even and how we
know things and also probing and
learning uh mathematical structures to
such an extent that he builds on
some of the investigations that had been
done in this
period before him to create the
foundations of a way of investigating
processes that happen and change
continuously instead of by leaps and
bounds and so on forming the foundation
of what we now call the calculus
you